Michelle yo is returning for section 31
movie
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
move your Channel
[Music]
guys if you're a regular side tracker
you'll know that I've been talking about
trouble between Alex kurtzman's secret
hideout and Paramount that Alex kurtzman
was promising that Michelle Gill would
return for the section 31 TV series he
promised and that at least part of that
promise got him the Starfleet Academy
show that he really really wanted the
problem Michelle yeoh was not really
available to do a TV series she has just
won the Oscar she can pretty much do
whatever she wants and she just wasn't
that Keen to do a TV series
but Alice kurtzman looks like he
persevered and looks like he got his win
in the end because they negotiated now
this deal was supposed to be announced
on April 5th a week before that we got
Starfleet Academy announced just
randomly on a Wednesday afternoon for no
good reason
this was supposed to be announced then
[Music]
I'm first contacting on April the 5th
they would announce the Michelle yo
series however it got a little bit
complicated and they were having to
negotiate quite heavily with Michelle yo
that negotiation led to instead of a
series or even a mini-series a straight
to Paramount plus movie
what do you call pain I call foreplay
she has said I'm beyond thrilled to
return to my Star Trek Family into the
role I've Loved for so long section 31
has been near and dear to my heart since
I began the Journey of playing Philippa
all the way back when this new golden
age of Star Trek launched to see her
finally get the moment is a dream come
true in a year that's shown me
incredible power of never giving up on
your dreams we can't wait to share
what's in store for you and until then
live long and prosper unless Emperor
Giorgio decrees otherwise
it's a great statement
so what has happened and how have we got
here so right it's basically comes down
to this
section 31 has been in the pipeline for
many years but it's been struggled to
get to fruition because of lots of other
Star Trek that was going on the plan was
always for section 31 to replace Star
Trek Picard but then Michelle yo won the
Oscar and got very very busy so they had
to renegotiate that plan in the meantime
Alex kurtzman used Oscar winning
Michelle yo to get Starfleet Academy
approved a project that he is wanted to
do for a very very long time a project
that he will be co-showing and that he
is planning to direct
I have heard through my sources that
section 31 was always a project that
Alex kurtzman really really wants to do
and what he really wants to do is direct
oscar-winning Michelle yo in this
project he has Ambitions really Beyond
Star Trek and this project will not hurt
those Ambitions at all
so finally he gets to actually direct an
oscar-winning actress in a movie
it doesn't have to be this way
this is Alex kurtzman's wet dream
however I am hearing that it is not
actually sewn down that Paramount will
let him direct so let's see what happens
there
but this is breaking news this was kind
of slightly unexpected again because it
was generally considered in the industry
that this was probably not going to
happen that Alex kurtzman had
overstretched himself and was actually
making promises he couldn't fulfill
but the one thing he had going for him
is that Michelle yo is in incredibly
loyal actress when she says her Star
Trek Family she is not joking she
understands that Star Trek has really
helped her career in the last few years
[Music]
it gave us some exposure on Western
television that maybe she hasn't had at
times it allowed her to play a character
which really pushed the range of her
acting most actors and actresses love
playing a bad guy and a bad guy that
they can really kind of overact and
really throw themselves into is even
better so yeah Michelle yo has
absolutely loved this character and
she's a loved Star Trek and she's been a
loyal to Star Trek don't look at him
look at us so this will be your second
Universe your third timeline
depends on how you look at it
get it like this
[Music]
so you will have had to move a few
things around she will maybe have to say
no to a couple of things to be able to
do this
she doesn't have to do it but she is
obviously decided to do it because of
her loyalty and Alex kurtzman Star Trek
is seriously going to benefit from it
the Kudos the Paramount you're going to
get from getting a Star Trek movie
starring an academy award-winning
actress is massive and I am absolutely
certain they're going to milk it for
everything they can
do not be surprised if this movie at
some point gets talked about being a
cinematic release instead of straight to
Paramount plus because this project is
going to get a lot of attention and if
it gets enough positive attention
don't think a cinematic release is
impossible
but guys what do you think section 31
the movie obviously a massive compromise
in lots of ways for Paramount but a huge
success in lots of other ways get in the
comments though and tell me exactly what
you're thinking about this breaking news
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
as we get the news to you as quickly as
we possibly can also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where most of our new videos appear
first and for a small contribution that
helps the channel each week you get to
see it without the adverts as always
please stay safe I'll see you next time
[Music]